yo has gone on it's a bit difficult to
come out here after Anthony just came up
and all the girls are gone mad for him
yeah that's the sympathy vote right
there but I summer drank this much for
the effort
oh cool she was already an
internationally acclaimed model when she
launched the tours and collaboration
with highest reach I am Marks and
Spencer and this year she launched her
first woman's wear collection with
online retailer misguided the 96 piece
London for misguided range was an
instant hit with sellout pieces and
celebrity fans ensuring another
collection is due to drop this summer
this car was not only an inspiration to
myself all young black girls across the
country but just all young girls in
general this is the amazing glamorous
entrepreneur of the year is your than
done yo man like Stasi though you know
Satmar like that um okay um yeah so
every time I have to do a speech I
always mess it up like I'm a hot mess
I'm always mumbling I'm always swearing
drinking way too much so I thought to
myself you know what you're getting
honored with the world Entrepreneur of
the year so like maybe come correctly
professional no dafuq what you want to
say so I'm trying to be my growing woman
professional boss [ __ ] vibe right now
but your hair like yeah I hope I'm
giving that to you guys
yeah so um first off I want to thank Joe
and glamoured and we were I can't see
are you right there oh my bad sorry
thank you so much for this award
it honestly means so much I've won an
award in the path of this is the first
one for entrepreneurs oh it's like means
so much to me so thank you so much I
have to they got the boss magnets and
Patti's the founder of misguided and the
team that you know they really fully
allowed me to explore as a designer when
buddy was like to medicine Nitin was
like listen you you're your boss you're
my boss now if I wrong I go I'm a boss
why I'm admitting bossman putting me I'm
a boss and I have Rick Ross to my head
I'm a boss I like y'all imma ball so I'm
going to claim that own it and run with
it
so yeah so thank you for allowing me to
yeah be a boss thank you to storm and
fluid world and ruse I am Simon Emily
por la Daniel the whole squad storm for
supporting me and believe in my dream
and yeah and also lastly I want to like
and it wrap it up real quick I'm always
getting like girls and even grown-ass
women like come up to me and ask me that
how do you do it de nada
and I have to say once I started to
change my mindset and eliminating the
the self limiting beliefs I had even
last night I was like in my bed writing
in my diary yes I'm still trying I'm 26
I write my diary
I was like talking about tonight as I
okay I'm going to be accepting the Lord
for tripping all over the air even
though I don't feel like I'm deserving
and then I have to kind of like sit back
importantly like wait why are you doing
this why are you sabotaging yourself why
you like talking so negative yourself
like you are deserving you should be
proud like you came up the name London
like that's that pop it's London where
you're from and your family name like a
[ __ ] sits like you did that
like your genius rely on wife oh yeah
so let me just say like loosen the cells
taught the negative tool you just have
to just get rid of that and you have to
just think positively and think of a
single possibility because anything is
[ __ ] possible I'm a girl from
flipping Greenford got pregnant at 19
and I'm here in front of you lot so yeah
i think i felt quite carton or or mate
let me just go because i feel like I was
on a roll and now I'm just mumbling so
how do you have a great night guys and
thank you so much
[Applause]